and michelle young seasons next have you
spoken to her she's about to start her
journey what advice have you given
i've spoken to her as much as i can
because i know it's any day now that
they're going to take her phone away
and i think the biggest advice i've
given her is to just be open
you know don't close yourself off too
early i think guys can surprise you
uh you know weeks later when you don't
expect it are there any guys on your
season that you think would make a good
fit for michelle
oh that is a good question
i actually think josh would be a good
match for michelle for sure how come
they just have very similar
personalities you know and he is such a
sweetheart and i think
that's what she's looking for you know
someone who is just so kind-hearted and
that's something that josh really offers
when i talk to every guy tonight they
said the craziest moment that they
witnessed was when you accidentally
called
aaron thomas i'm always going to be in
your corner thank you
thanks thomas
[Applause]
i will never forgive myself for that um
i have no i really have no words at this
point no comment
i've apologized a hundred times it'll
never be good enough though
who do you think out of all the men was
the hardest to reunite with tonight
probably michael i knew it would be hard
but also i knew
tonight was going to offer that closure
that i needed so it was really nice to
also see him and
kind of have our final words together
and and move forward
he kind of said that he was low-key
hoping you do end up single because he
kind of still wants to give things a
chance with you so what was it like when
you heard that
i was a little surprised at first but
also i've
since kind of closed those chapters and
have moved forward
i just don't see myself going backwards
and revisiting
the relationships with these men that
i've already had the opportunity to do
so
you have said though that one of your
biggest fears is sending the wrong
person home
is that still a fear of yours or if
you've kind of made peace with that fear
i've officially made peace with
everything that has happened and
i'm in a place where i am very happy
with my life and where i'm at and that's
all i can do
you know to continue to move forward
let's talk about thomas what do you
think about the fact that he
didn't show up here in person tonight
and showed up via video chat
part of me is not surprised but also he
was such
old news to me that i wouldn't have
cared either way
i mean it was nice to you know get his
apology and kind of
let go of that grudge and move forward
but also he's old news
in my life so whatever
he said he saw something great in you do
we believe
him he probably saw something great in
me but also that's a great line to say
to any girl
you know so it's hard to know when he's
being sincere and when he's
being a rehearsed man you're selfish
unkind and a liar
your bachelor audition ends tonight
so get out do you have any regrets on
how you sent him home or does he deserve
it
i have no regrets with how i sent him
home you know i was only focused on me
and him in that moment i didn't care who
saw or that there were cameras
i was just living my truth and my
emotions and what's your thoughts on him
now
i still think he has a lot of growing to
do you know i don't think he is ready
for an engagement
but i do believe people learn a lot
about themselves when they watch this
back and i think
he is doing that as we speak also you
sent andrew home which was pretty
emotional and reuniting with him tonight
you did kind of ask him after reading
his note
to stay and he said no do you think
about if he had chosen to stay how
different your ending might be or do you
think it may have still had the same
ending
there was a line that andrew said when i
watched that back which was i'm not
going to stay
just for her to not give me a rose again
and after thinking about it he's right
you know as much as i wanted to
selfishly spend more time with him
he wasn't going to be my person at the
end so it was best that he left
so we still haven't seen your ending we
saw the preview you're telling caitlyn
to book your
flight home so what do you want to
happen
i want someone to book my flight home
so what can we expect expect the
unexpected i don't think
this has ever happened in the history of
the bachelor or the bachelorette before
you said you don't have a traditional
ending so elaborate a little bit
how so i mean there's a traditional
format that you you expect when you
watch the bachelorette
and that gets shaken up pretty quick
let's talk about the three guys you have
left first there's blake he kind of
joined late
and he said he's not in love with you
yet he's still in your final three what
makes you keep him around
sometimes you don't have to speak words
to know how you feel and
given the time that he was there you
know i was in the same place as him we
have these strong emotions but we both
weren't in a place to express our love
and that was something i was okay with
and then there's greg who's the only
person you kind of has said so far that
you're falling for him
do the other guys even stand a chance i
mean greg obviously got my first
impression rose the first one-on-one so
it's very obvious that i've had my eyes
on him from the beginning
how it goes i mean we'll have to see we
do see greg storming off
what can you tease about why he's
storming off you know the closer you get
to the end the harder things get for
anybody you are approaching an
engagement and that can be
scary and you have to ask yourself some
tough questions and then there's justin
who did get your first kiss and he's
your third so what about him is you know
why you kept him around for your final
three you know it's really unfortunate
because him and i had an early
connection but it wasn't quite
shown until later on and so i think
bachelor nation is going to get to see
that a little bit as we move forward and
he's just someone that i've really
enjoyed spending my time with and it was
very easy and i mean that's all you're
looking for when you're looking for a
partner and you've said like this is
some of the best guys ever so who do you
think would make a good bachelor from
your group of guys
i have two votes and i'm voting for
either andrew or michael as the next
bachelor
they both have so much to offer i think
they're both in a place where they are
ready to settle down and find their
person
i think they are so mature and would be
great husbands and
i mean michael's already a great father
and they're just so deserving and i want
nothing but the best for them
your finale is just a few weeks away how
excited are you to not have to keep any
more secrets and hopefully be out in the
open with a guy that you have chosen
i've really been living under a rock
this whole time so you know come august
9th i'm ready to get out of the house
and move forward with my life
um and just really figure things out and
what the future holds for me
[Music]